Traduttore: Francesca Pace
Revisore: Barbara Nettl
Nel 2013, prendere un caffè,
per me significava esattamente questo:
prendere un caffè al bar.
Mi sedevo,
sapevo che il caffè percorreva
centinaia di migliaia di chilometri
e finiva nella mia tazzina.
Nel 2013 la vita del caffè
finiva nella tazzina.
Tutto questo però fin quando
non ho cambiato il mio punto di vista
su cosa significa sul serio
prendere un caffè al bar.
Cambiare il punto di vista
non è una cosa che noi scegliamo.
Non mi sveglio un giorno e dico:
oggi cambio il mio punto di vista.
No, purtroppo non succede così.
Io penso che cambiare il punto di vista
è un po' come innamorarsi.
Ci capita, semplicemente,
senza poterlo scegliere.
Ed io mi sono innamorato
del mio nuovo punto di vista
su cosa significa
prendere un caffè al bar.
Oggi, qui a Genova, al TED,
vi racconterò come grazie a TED
ho scoperto che una linea
può diventare un cerchio,
e quello che era un problema
può diventare una soluzione.
Nel 2013, io sono architetto,
mi stavo laureando in architettura
e durante delle ricerche per la mia tesi,
sono incappato in questo fantastico
TED talk tenuto al TED Salon di Londra
da Michael Pawlyn,
un architetto designer.
Michael Pawlyn parlava di biomimetica,
di come poter utilizzare la natura
per progettare architetture,
per progettare oggetti,
per progettare opere di ingegneria
in maniera sostenibile
e in maniera naturale.
Biomimetica è una parola difficile
che significa
"copia e incolla dalla natura".
Ovviamente noi sappiamo perfettamente
che la natura ci ha dato
migliaia e migliaia di esempi
e tutt'oggi ci dà esempi
su come progettare
in maniera sostenibile
e in maniera razionale.
Un esempio su tutti: sapete perché
i treni veloci hanno quel muso?
Gli ingegneri hanno scoperto
che il martin pescatore, che è un uccello,
utilizza il suo becco
in una maniera fantastica:
in pratica lui aspetta
su un ramo il pesce,
appena lo vede si fionda
a una velocità impressionante,
arriva in acqua e non emette
un singolo schizzo.
Cosa hanno pensato gli ingegneri:
perché non utilizziamo questo muso
sui nostri treni superveloci?
Risultato: treni più veloci,
consumano di meno
e quando entrano nelle gallerie
ad altissima velocità
utilizzano molta meno energia.
Ovviamente possiamo ben immaginare
che gli esempi che la natura ci dà
per progettare in maniera sostenibile,
sono molteplici.
Michael Pawlyn infatti ci fa
tantissimi altri esempi in questo TED talk
che vi consiglio anche di vedere.
Ma la cosa che mi fa alzare dalla sedia
nel 2013, è un piccolissimo intervento
che Michael prende in considerazione.
Lui ci parla infatti di poter utilizzare
non solo le forme della natura,
ma anche e soprattutto i processi naturali
che permettono a tutti gli attori
di vivere in maniera armonica l'un l'altro
come una foresta fondamentalmente.
Lui parla di blue economy,
di closed loop economy,
di economia circolare.
L'economia circolare non è nient'altro
che copiare dalla natura i processi
e portarli nella nostra realtà.
E lui parlava fondamentalmente
di creare aziende, di creare imprese,
di creare nuovi posti di lavoro
che copiassero tal quale
i processi naturali.
Ovviamente pensare
che la natura poteva ispirare
la progettazione di nuovi posti di lavoro,
creare nuovi lavori, era assurdo.
A quel punto io dovevo saperne di più,
dovevo capire come era possibile
riuscire a portare la natura
in processi antropici, in processi umani,
come quello appunto
della creazione del lavoro e dell'economia.
Internet ha fatto il suo corso.
Dovevo sapere qualsiasi cosa
su questa economia circolare.
Fortunatamente abbiamo Internet,
e digitando su qualsiasi motore di ricerca
sono venuto a conoscenza
di questa economia circolare.
L'economia circolare esiste.
L'economia circolare è reale.
Adesso viviamo in un contesto
di economia lineare,
dove estraiamo qualcosa, la trasformiamo
e la buttiamo in discarica.
L'economia circolare invece ci dice
che gli output di un processo
possono diventare gli input
di un altro processo produttivo,
in maniera virtuosa.
L'esempio che mi ha fatto
veramente impazzire
è quello di un ristorante.
Questo ristorante ha scelto di utilizzare
il 90% dei suoi materiali
utilizzando carta, cartone o cellulosa.
In questo esempio i piatti.
Alla fine della giornata il ristorante
non butta i resti di carta,
cartone e cellulosa
nell'umido o nell'indifferenziata,
ma li cede a un maneggio che li utilizza
per i cavalli come lettiera.
I cavalli dormono, anche se si dice
che dormono in piedi,
i cavalli hanno bisogno delle lettiere.
Alla fine del processo appunto,
quando i cavalli hanno utilizzato
queste lettiere,
piuttosto che buttare
le lettiere utilizzate,
vengono cedute ad un impianto
di compostaggio
dove i lombrichi utilizzano le lettiere
per produrre compost
dall'altissimo valore nutrizionale
per le piante.
L'humus di lombrico,
il compost di lombrico,
è la Ferrari dei compost, è il compost
dal più alto valore aggiunto.
Una volta che il compost è stato prodotto
i vermi in eccesso non vengono smaltiti
ma vengono ceduti ad un impianto
che alleva storioni.
Lo storione ci dà il caviale,
che viene venduto al ristorante,
che lo serve nei suoi piatti di carta,
che poi vengono dati al maneggio.
E così via.
In pratica quello che era
carta, che era cartone diventa caviale.
Qualcosa senza valore, quello che era
considerato uno scarto,
diventa qualcosa da un altissimo
valore aggiunto.
Ci rendiamo tutti conto che un'idea
del genere, concepire l'economia
come economia circolare ci può aprire
a delle soluzioni infinite,
basti pensare che la carta
è diventata caviale.
Ma dovevo saperne di più.
E Internet ancora una volta
ha fatto il suo corso.
Digitando un'altra volta
"economia circolare"
su un qualsiasi motore di ricerca
vi renderete conto
che ci sono decine e decine di startup,
di aziende, di persone,
che hanno fatto dell'economia circolare
il proprio punto di vista.
Loro hanno capito che l'economia lineare,
nella quale adesso noi purtroppo
sopravviviamo,
è ormai un sistema obsoleto,
che deve essere cambiato,
a favore dell'economia circolare.
Ora il problema era unico, che io volevo
entrare in quest'economia circolare,
per me era l'unico modo reale di concepire
un sistema economico
con l'economia circolare.
Però non avevo nè un ristorante,
nè un maneggio, non coltivavo i vermi,
non avevo gli storioni,
quindi avevo bisogno di un caso studi
che fosse vicino alla mia realtà,
e grazie a Internet,
ancora una volta Internet,
sono venuto a conoscenza di un esempio
fantastico di economia circolare.
Nel 1990 il professore Shu-Ting Chang,
dell'Università di Hong Kong,
un micologo di fama internazionale,
stava studiando come utilizzare
substrati alternativi
per la coltivazione
di funghi commestibili.
Ad oggi i funghi si coltivano
con la paglia o con lo stallatico.
Il professore Shu-Ting Chang ha scoperto
che altri substrati
potevano essere utilizzati
e il migliore era il fondo di caffè.
In pratica Shu-Ting Chang ha dimostrato
che dal caffè si fanno i funghi.
L'immagine del professore con questo caffè
che esce dal suo cervello
e con i funghi che escono dall'altra parte
mi ha completamente invaso.
Non so se avete capito,
ma io vengo dalla provincia di Napoli,
Torre del Greco.
Il caffè non manca, i funghi ci sono,
e quindi ho pensato:
ecco, questo è il mio caso studi.
Quindi cosa ho fatto?
Ho studiato i funghi.
Il professore mi ha spiegato
come funziona la vita del fungo.
Innanzitutto quello che noi
chiamiamo fungo
non è nient'altro che il corpo fruttifero,
quello che noi mangiamo è la parte finale
del processo del fungo.
Quello che invece noi chiamiamo,
il vero fungo è il micelio,
che è una radice sottoterra.
Però avevo bisogno di altre informazioni,
e quindi Internet ancora una volta
mi ha dato una mano.
Internet in questa storia ci sarà sempre
come avete ben visto.
E Internet è la chiave di lettura
di questo mio nuovo punto di vista,
del cambiamento che io sto
portando avanti.
Grazie a Internet ho scoperto
che coltivare i funghi dal fondo di caffè
era possibile, lo stavano già facendo
altre startup in altri paesi.
Quindi in pratica io avevo il caso studi,
la realtà di Napoli, di Torre del Greco,
dovevo solo combinarle
all'interno del mio garage,
perché ovviamente non c'è startup
senza un garage.
Allora il 19 settembre del 2013, una data
carissima ai partenopei, San Gennaro,
inizio nel mio garage
la mia sperimentazione:
vado al bar del mio amico, Claudio,
vado a prendere per la prima volta
il fondo di caffè,
tutti ovviamente ridevano
di questa mia scelta,
lo unisco al micelio, al seme del fungo,
chiudo in una scatola
e dopo quattro settimane abbiamo questo:
(Applausi)
Questi.
Questi sono funghi freschi commestibili
coltivati dal fondo di caffè.
Non sanno di caffè ovviamente
e la particolarità
è che per 100 grammi di prodotto
abbiamo 8,1 grammi di proteine,
sali minerali e lovastatine.
Le lovastatine sono dei veri e propri
farmaci naturali.
In pratica riescono ad abbassare
la pressione sanguigna
e riducono l'assimilazione
del colesterolo cattivo
all'interno delle nostre arterie.
Quindi in pratica io in un garage,
dal fondo di caffè e il fungo
avevo creato un vero e proprio
laboratorio.
Quando ti rendi conto che i funghi
possono convertire qualcosa
senza valore nutrizionale
come il fondo di caffè e farlo diventare
proteine e lovastatine,
ti rendi conto che il tuo punto di vista
sui funghi cambia.
Perché io ho visto i funghi da quel giorno
come delle vere e proprie
macchine biologiche
che riescono con una frazione
dell'energia necessaria per produrre
altri tipi di proteine come proteine
animali o altre proteine vegetali,
i funghi appunto utilizzano veramente
pochissima energia.
Il problema ovviamente era questo,
che io mi immaginavo un'industria
formata da produttori di funghi
dal fondo di caffè e ho pensato:
non è possibile che io sia l'unico
in Italia che è impazzito
per questo tipo di procedimento.
E allora Internet, ancora una volta,
ha fatto il suo corso.
Ho scoperto che in Italia
c'è un intero movimento di persone
che fanno parte
della strategia Rifiuti Zero,
che pensano,
che sono convinti e dimostrano
che l'economia circolare
non è solo una scelta ma è l'unica scelta,
è una scelta obbligata, che deve portare
alla sostituzione totale
dell'attuale sistema lineare
di produzione.
Su Internet sono venuto a conoscenza
che in Toscana c'era un ragazzo
che stava studiando esattamente
il mio stesso caso studi,
stava utilizzando il fondo di caffè
per produrre funghi, Antonio.
Antonio, il caso ha voluto che avesse
già fatto innamorare di questa idea
un imprenditore giapponese che era
qui in Italia, manco a farlo apposta,
a investire in startup
dall'alto valore tecnologico
ma soprattutto
dall'alto valore ambientale.
Ho chiamato subito Antonio,
non potevo lasciarmi scappare
questa opportunità.
Alla fine del 2013 gli invio un'email
e nel 2014 Antonio, Tomohiro
e il sottoscritto fondiamo la nostra
piccola startup agricola
che produce funghi dal caffè espresso
e lo facciamo ad oggi
in Toscana e a Firenze.
Il nostro lavoro è semplicissimo:
tutti i giorni ci svegliamo,
con le nostre biciclette raccogliamo
il fondo di caffè dai bar di Firenze,
che sono felicissimi
ovviamente di darcelo,
lo portiamo nella nostra piccola azienda
e trasformiamo il fondo di caffè
in funghi freschi da vendere
al mercato locale,
kit per la coltivazione casalinga e,
siccome i rifiuti non esistono,
il nostro fondo esausto lo utilizziamo
per produrci humus di lombrico,
copiando ovviamente l'idea
di quel ristorante.
Noi avevamo creato
con cinque step la nostra economia,
il nostro piccolo esempio
di economia circolare.
Il problema qual era però?
Che fin quando noi produciamo cibo,
fin quando noi produciamo funghi
e kit per la coltivazione casalinga,
noi non stiamo cambiando
veramente la società.
La cosa che ci porta veramente a cambiare
il modello economico da lineare
a circolare è l'informazione.
Noi ci eravamo resi conto
che il nostro progetto
andava oltre la produzione di funghi.
Noi stavamo creando un messaggio
stavamo creando della conoscenza.
E ci siamo domandati:
ma come è possibile che, secondo voi,
una società agricola
perché una società agricola non può andare
nelle scuole e fare educazione ambientale?
Perché dobbiamo sempre aspettare
che le istituzioni facciano qualcosa?
Le istituzioni che quando ci hanno visto
sono rimaste allibite.
Noi eravamo una chimera
dal punto di vista legale.
Noi siamo un'azienda agricola
che non utilizza la terra.
Noi non abbiamo neanche
un ettaro di terra.
La Regione Toscana per capire
che noi eravamo un'azienda agricola
ha dovuto creare una legge ad hoc
e definirci la prima azienda agricola
regionale senza terra.
Probabilmente siamo la prima
azienda agricola regionale italiana.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
E questo significava cambiare,
far cambiare il punto di vista.
Se le istituzioni
avevano cambiato il punto di vista,
allora eravamo pronti
a entrare nelle scuole
e a far cambiare il punto di vista
a chi veramente ci stava a cuore
i futuri cittadini, perché sono loro
che dovranno poi
adottare l'economia circolare
nei loro stili di vita.
Dopo soli tre anni quel caffè,
quella semplice tazzina di caffè
è diventata un'idea,
è diventata un business.
Noi produciamo non solo funghi
ma produciamo anche ricchezza,
noi produciamo posti di lavoro,
noi creiamo valore aggiunto
da quello che era considerato uno scarto.
E' paradossale pensare che il fondo
di caffè che viene considerato uno scarto
rappresenta il 99,8%
della massa totale del caffè.
L'espresso che noi beviamo
è solo lo 0,2% che va nella tazzina.
Ogni volta che noi buttiamo il caffè
nell'immondizia, stiamo gettando il 99,8%
di una pianta che ha polifenoli,
ha carbonio, azoto, lignina,
tutti elementi che possono
essere utilizzati per produrci funghi.
Questa storia di economia circolare
ovviamente deve concludersi
in maniera circolare.
Siamo partiti dal TEDtalk
di Michael Pawlyn
che mi ha portato qui oggi
a Genova a dimostrarvi
come effettivamente è possibile
cambiare il punto di vista.
Oggi siamo qui per dimostrare agli altri
che è possibile
ed è semplice cambiare il punto di vista.
Basta solamente fare un piccolo sforzo,
basta solamente rendersi conto
che l'attuale modello economico lineare
è un modello obsoleto.
Noi siamo abituati a pensare
in maniera lineare, ma ormai è alla luce,
è alla portata di tutti il fatto
che il modello di economia lineare
ormai ha dimostrato i suoi limiti,
li sta dimostrando.
E noi quindi col nostro progetto
vogliamo dimostrare che l'unico vero modo
di creare economia è quello
dell'economia circolare,
dove appunto non esistono scarti
ma esistono
solo ed esclusivamente risorse.
In questi tre anni noi ci siamo resi conto
che l'unico modo appunto di concepire
l'intero progetto è quello del cerchio.
Siamo partiti dal caffè,
siamo ritornati al caffè.
Siamo partiti da un TED
e siamo ritornati ad un TED.
Tutto questo per dirvi cosa, oggi.
Che quello che io vi chiedo
è un ultimo sforzo.
Sebbene sia normale pensare
che l'unico modo di concepire
l'economia lineare sia quello attuale
io vi chiedo di fare solamente
un piccolo sforzo di immaginazione
e di cambiare il vostro punto di vista
la vostra prospettiva e pensare
che quello che fino ad oggi è considerato
una linea può diventare un cerchio
e che l'economia circolare
è un'economia che si basa
su una semplicissima
e inconfutabile idea
dove nulla si crea, nulla si distrugge
ma tutto si trasforma.
(Applausi)
Grazie.